so when we've been looking at compound
regions so far we've restricted our
kinds of functions to ones like this and
they're kind of nice and neatly designed
so they intersect at exactly two spots
and there's kind of a nice neat place
where the area begins the area ends you
just need to identify your upper and
lower bounds and then off you go
subtract one integral from the other but
not all functions do this
some think functions are more
complicated they wiggle around and they
give you regions that require you to be
a bit more careful an example of which
looks like this so what do we got here
we've got a cubic and a parabola and
because of the way particularly the
cubic it sort of waves around up and
down and you can see the compound region
the the area that's sort of enclosed by
both curves together there's not just
one of them there's two of them
now we've looked at things like this
before when we were looking at areas
beneath and above the axis and we
noticed that sometimes you have to
subtract an area rather than add it
because it ends up being negative so the
subtraction of a negative gives you a
positive and there's going to be a
similar situation here if you have a
think about it again logically from the
viewpoint of each area individually okay
so let's have a look at area one you can
see that in area one I've got to
identify which in fact both areas I've
got identify which curve is above and
which curve is below because they used
to attract one from the other well for
area one you can see that the curve over
the top is going to be let's see it's
too fancy I think so it's gotta be this
red one over the top right now this is
the cubic function so for working out
area one I'm going to have f of X which
is X cubed plus 2x minus 4x f of X will
be on the on the top and then I will
subtract G of X which is this parabola x
squared plus 2x so that's how I'm going
to evaluate a 1 but then when I cross
over to work out a 2 because now the
parabola has now gone above the cubic
just for this little portion of the
domain so in this case it's going to be
the blue function G of X and I'm going
to
tract the red function f of X so what
I've got to do is split up a 1 and a 2
and my integrals are going to have f of
X take away G of X and then G of X take
away f of X so you've got to be quite
careful with that let's have a go at
doing this to work it out where a 1 and
a 2 are going to start and I of course
need to find out these important spots
here these are the points of
intersection between the two curves as
you guys have identified in previous
lessons the way to find points of
intersection is to solve simultaneously
so let's have a go at doing that now to
find points of intersection and I'm
going to re-emphasize that it's always
valuable to actually say what you're
doing using some words the equations of
course to do the heavy lifting but I
want to know what the equations stand
for especially in questions like these
where you've got all different kinds of
things you're evaluating it's not like
there's just one equation there will be
several equations and so I want to know
what each equation signifies so here I'm
finding the points of intersection in
other words when does f of X equal G of
X when do these two things collide so
I'm going to do my substitution on the
basis of what I've on defined each of
the functions to be this f of X M is G
of X so let's see here I've got X cubed
plus 2x squared minus 4x and that's
going to be equal to x squared plus 2x
okay so what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to tidy things up and I want to
just be careful with my algebra because
as you might imagine if I miss a minus
sign here or if I do something wrong
with the arithmetic of collecting like
terms then I'll get the wrong point of
intersection and it doesn't matter how
good my remedy is to integrate I'll be
integrating from the wrong place to the
wrong place so care needs to be taken
every step I guess is what I'm trying to
say I can see on the left hand side and
the right hand side I've got these let's
use a different color here like orange
I've got x squared terms and then I've
also got X terms there's an X cubed term
on the left hand side but it doesn't
cancel with anything so I'll leave that
X cubed there I'm going to get
everything on the left hand
since the X cubed is already there so
I'll subtract x squared from both sides
which leaves me with this and then I'm
going to subtract 2x from both sides
which gives me this now because I've got
a bit more time here to explain I am
going to dwell on the fact that you can
hear in the way that I'm speaking I use
a very particular form of language when
I describe the operation to go from one
line to the other I know a lot of people
will sometimes say oh I'm gonna move the
2x to the other side and I see what
they're meaning they're trying to get
everything on the left-hand side rather
than the right-hand side but I'm going
to strongly recommend against number one
using that language and number two even
thinking in that way because nothing
really moves what really is going on is
that you have an equation left hand side
right hand side are equal so if they
start off equal then so long as you do
the same thing to both sides then they
will remain equal on the next line now
the operation that I've done to both
sides is I have subtracted 2x from the
right hand side and I've subtracted 2x
from the left hand side and that
preserves the Equality now the reason
why I'm emphasizing this is because like
I said before the the primary era the
most common one that people mark up with
questions like this is your science end
up being wrong your integrals when
you're evaluating them you forget to put
a minus sign in one of those upper or
lower bounds or you put the minus sign
there and then your substitution marks
up or of course when you're doing the
actual evaluation of a definite integral
when you're integrating from A to B of
course it is part of the integral itself
the whole process of evaluating a
definite integral to work out the
primitive and then you evaluate at the
top and you subtract the bottom now that
guy right there that minus sign is a
huge trouble maker for so many people
because if there are negatives in this F
of a then you're going to have a minus
of a negative the double negative trip
people up all the time so that's why I'm
just dwelling on that for a moment it's
this sermon this thousands of times that
students will do this and they're like
ah I got that the hard part of this
right I got all the integration right
but I messed up something very simple
all right so that's enough stalling on
that I've got now everything on the left
hand side
and remembering that what I'm trying to
do is find points of intersection the
most natural thing to do next is to
factorize and once I've got factors I
can identify the solutions of that
appropriately so I can see there's a
common factor of X which leaves me we
have x squared plus X minus 6 and that
quadratic on the inside of those
brackets I'm searching for that pair of
numbers that adds to one that's a bit
sneaky there's a one hiding in there and
multipliers to negative six maybe you
can think of it it's going to be here's
my two factors that are remaining X plus
3 X minus 2 X plus 3 X minus 2 equals 0
so from each of these three factors I'm
going to identify one of the points of
intersection or I should say the X
values for the points of intersection
because to get a point you need
coordinates so here I've got X equal to
0 here I've got x equals negative 3 and
then here equals is x equals 2 which as
I look back to the graph that was
provided to me is nice because it's
actually a graph that's to scale so
let's have a look at where each of those
points is here's a color I haven't used
yet
x equals 0 was the first one I'd
identify which is right there and in
some ways you could have seen that from
the graph without the algebra but we
couldn't do the other points without the
algebra then you've got this point over
here on the left hand side that looks to
be my x equals negative 3 and then
you've got this last one over here on
the right hand side that looks to be my
x equals 2 so find the points of
intersection or the X values for those
points was some work but I needed that
to work out where my integrals start and
end